I don't know if you can see I have this
weird line here because I burn burned
myself when this morning why because I
got one of those metal 1970s ice ice
machines ice snow machine ice tray thank
you
ice tray and that it's hard to open it
it's hard to crack it open so what I did
was I put it on the stove yeah you all
see where this tale is going no twists
and turns in this straightforward
narrative put it on the stove heat it up
for like three seconds I swear turn it
off then later just casually grab it
burn myself when Dad that's a big one
yelled out narrating for no one big one
gets a burn no one was there burned
myself that happened and this is what's
crazy today tonight's monologue is about
how I hate hurting myself because it
reminds me of how creepy my body is that
happened this morning
this monologues about I didn't do this
just to have a perfect segue into this
monologue I'm not alone at home like for
my art but here we are
last week I cut myself same kitchen same
man I just can't handle it
I cut myself with a knife because I was
trying to open listen open a thing of
tabasco knife is not necessary but I
picked I did a couple picks I was like
taking too long knife cuz I'm a goddamn
man started picking at it and as I was
picking at it picking I was like this is
stupid I'm gonna cut my and then I cut
myself immediately as I was having that
thought and I went that's deep
I'm always what is this the Wonder Years
that's a deep one I'm gonna get to know
my father this summer you know you're
like
narrating for no one and that doesn't
save time that's a job for the
fingernail the plastic seal atop one of
those things that's a job for him and I
feel happy for the fingernail in that
situation that's one of the few
remaining jobs for the fingernail go get
it fingernail escape people we used him
for everything
digging all that cave digging foraging
Kalan back at Pumas they were the king
now with her fingernails good for back
scratches drunken lady fights on vh1 and
the occasional sultry unassisted Spanish
guitar solo good lord that man plays
like he has five small picks stay
thirsty my friends I put a lot of stock
in that man's playing like he has five
small fix you were like okay it wasn't
that bad of a cut when I cut myself but
here's why I hate cuts they remind me
that we're all just bags of blood you me
bags of blood I don't mean to get all
McConaughey and true detective on you
mostly liquid sloshing around think
about that when you're talking to your
friend Earl Earl is mostly blood it's
just a huge head body legs it's all just
keeping the real hem inside your skin is
just the lid on the Tupperware you take
that away that'd just be a blood tidal
wave like from the shining spilling down
the hall merging with other people to
turn into waves of blood till there's
just a huge sea of blood and that's the
whole world
I love the thought that there's one man
at home watching like man on TV he's
talking about to see your blood that's
the sign I've been waiting for clown
mouth my body freaks me out is what I'm
saying and I hate him and I'm tired of
not talking about it not just blood my
heart heart gross he's in charge
this gross pulsing rotten pomegranate is
the CEO my entire body runs on this tiny
little thing and it's involuntary that
freaks me out
involuntary arm voluntary move arm
thanks arm good arm muscles working on
his own hearts gone rogue he's just in
there overworked just like I got it I
got it I got it I got it I got it I got
it I got it I got it I got it I got it I
it I got it you go to bed still got it
still got so god dad she'll get it
still got it terrified Oh
terrified your lungs oh those are weird
too wet air bags flopping and filling
emptying all day constantly leaking like
cheap balloons gross call me out lungs
you gross sometimes people get high and
they freak out they're like huh oh man I
don't really smoke weed is this what it
sounds like
ah if I stop breathing I die that's not
paranoia that couldn't be more true
again I love one guy watching at home
like skeletons two skeletons are scary
you have one your in you you are a
skeleton that's everybody scary scary
skeletons dozens of you here watching
the show watching me hosting the show
also a skeleton just in a meat suit
skeleton look at huge Famers wide berth
and hips heads a little bit too big
skeleton everything's a skeleton
skeletons are everywhere they're reading
bedtime stories to children picture the
x-ray of that moment yeah yeah
terrifying good night moon right there
right there right there
they're giving you directions you the
skeleton you skeleton you're a skeleton
are you skeletons think of the x-ray
people having sex it's just two
skeletons always smiling all teeth gross
sex is two skeletons sometimes three
if you play your card right